Researchers from Georgia Tech are developing
warm skin for robots.
The active thermal sensing combines with traditional
force sensing to allow the robot to touch-identify
wood and aluminum with 96% accuracy.
And the acorn worm, one of our closet invertebrate
relatives can regrow every major body part
including its nervous system, internal organs
and its head.
And humans may share all of the genes they
use to do this.
Vsauce!
Kevin here - this is Mind Blow.
Digital capture of eyeballs is now a whole
lot easier.
Disney Research Zurich has developed a parametric
model that allows quicker, less-intrusive
reconstruction of eyes.
Using a database of pre-captured eyes a single
photo from the internet is all that's needed
to create the digital eyes and the system
also includes artistic control over parameters
like vein depth and thickness, iris geometry,
and pupil dilation.
The fitting technique algorithm works so well
it can even recreate digital versions of eyeball
from paintings.
So yeah.
Spiderwort grew an ear on an apple.
The company is developing an open source CO2
incubator as well as cellulose biomaterials
to grow cells in your house.
Basically, scaffolds for growing cells typically
come from animal or human tissue but they’re
developing cell wall architectures from the
plants and fungus kingdoms.
The system is in the pre-sale stage right
now and the hope is to allow low cost and
open source DIY kits for schools, labs and
garages.
Scientists at Harvard have invented a cigarette-smoking
robot.
The machine lights and then essentially inhales
and exhales the smoke from up to 10 cigarettes
at a time.
A tiny chip inside covered with living cells
from human lungs is then used to analyze the
effects.
They also have a 3D-printed heart-on-a-chip
device and the plan is to eventually create
an entire human-on-a-chip to link 10 organ-chips
together and study the entire human body.
Living organisms have been persuaded to make
chemical bonds not found in nature.
Researchers at Caltech are breeding molecules
with silicon-carbon compounds - something
only chemists could previously accomplish.
Synthetically created organosilicon compounds
are currently used in pharmaceuticals, semiconductors,
and also computer and TV screens.
And this new bonding method called directed
evolution is nontoxic, cheaper, more efficient
and easier to modify than chemical synthesis.
And this is more about reducing the need for
precious metals in making scilicon-carbon
bonds than it is about creating androids.
For now.
Two paralyzed monkeys can walk again thanks
to a brain-spine interface.
Neuroengieers at Brown University recorded
the electrical signals from the movement-controlling
area of the monkey’s brains, then decoded
and sent them to implanted electrodes on the
spine.
The signals stimulated the spinal cord and
the monkeys not only walked but reacted naturally
to the regained motion.
And they’re working on improving the hardware
with the hope it can someday be used to aid
paraplegic humans.
suitX is augmenting the power of human bodies.
The flexible exoskeletons are designed to
reduce injury and bolster productivity by
providing assistance lifting, squatting and
bending.
Three models backX, shoulderX and legX can
reduce muscle force up to 50%.
They’re currently aimed at helping construction
and factory workers but they also have the
Phoenix which is the world’s lightest exoskeleton
to help those with mobility disorders.
A new magnetic ink prints self-healing devices.
Microparticles organized by a magnetic field
become attracted to one in the event of a
tear - allowing the device to heal itself.
The repair can occur with a tear up to 3 millimeters
which is a record in self-healing systems
and the magnetic ink could be used to create
self-healing batteries and wearable electrical
circuits.
Finally, researchers from Northwestern University
have developed a wearable skin sensor to measure
the composition of your sweat.
I am a skin-like microfluidic device please
scan for biomarker information.
So it launches an app.
It provides that voice recognition that there's
a connection here.
And then the phone takes a picture of the
device and from analysis of the colors of
these different reservoirs that are filled
with these color-responsive chemical reagents,
we can determine quantitatively the glucose
level, the pH the lactate concentration, the
chloride concentration as well as the total
sweat loss during a given period of exercise.
I’m gonna leave you with a non-anthropomorphic
walking robot which means it doesn't walk
like this, it walks like, you'll see, and
as always - thanks for watching.
In the operating room the first light of its
kind is installed no portion of an operation
is ever in shadow.
Nor is the expectant father forgotten here
he can get the news officially and suffer
under the most comfortable circumstances possible.
And for mother, well she is only to call for
her baby and baby comes sliding through a
wall in a drawer-like basinet for a little
visit with the new mother.
In this two million dollar institution doors
are opened by remote control on the single
floor patients are easily moved from place
to place.
Dreams grounds for a dream hospital.
For exclusive Vsauce gear and a steady-flow
of mind-blowing LÜT subscribe to The Curiosity
Box.